big clamp down going on right now on
conservatives on social media and it's
important to remember
the history that conservatives have had
with social media social media is the
reason that conservatives
were ascendant for much of the last 10
years
because before that we were shut out of
the
mainstream media even when we did manage
to get presidents elected they were
pretty liberal like george bush for
instance
or the other george bush social media
allowed conservatives to have a voice
when we had been shut out of the tv
networks when we've been shut out of the
newspapers
when we'd been shut out of hollywood the
the new media
gave us that kind of freedom and now
they're taking that freedom
away the clampdown that's going on right
now
is pretty significant in that basically
every prominent right winger on social
media
is losing lots and lots and lots of
followers
and when people complain about this it
seems sort of petty it seems like a
vanity contest
oh no you lost 30 000 twitter followers
boohoo for you i've got real problems
but i i think actually that's sort of
why big tech is pursuing the strategy
because it sounds petty but it is
significant because if you take away
conservatives followers
all of a sudden conservatives no longer
have a voice and it doesn't just affect
some pundit
and it doesn't just affect some elected
representative
it affects all conservatives who can't
get our voice out there that's what
they're betting on
jake tapper came out and he said i don't
know how my
how many twitter followers i've lost
because i don't pay attention to that
because i'm an adult
which is not true jake tapper has
bragged about his twitter followers in
the past
but that's not even the point tapper
hasn't lost any twitter followers
actually they've increased significantly
over the past few days whereas every
prominent conservative just about
has lost a lot up to and including the
president who lost his entire voice on
social media
why does jake tapper gain followers why
is twitter gaming their system to give
him
a larger audience because jake tapper is
a submissive vessel for the liberal
establishment so obviously they're going
to reward him
and then he's going to continue to do
their bidding whereas for conservatives
we're not going to do that and so
twitter won't either twitter's
ridiculous excuse for the clampdown
up to and including the man that the
american people chose to be president at
least until january 20th
that guy's the duly elected president
twitter says
to clear up confusion about fluctuations
in follower accounts fluctuations it's
just going down by the way it's not
it's not like going up 50 000 and then
it's it's going down
to clear up the confusion in order to
prevent spam we regularly challenge
accounts to confirm details like
email and phone number until that info
is confirmed these accounts are not
included in follower accounts
that's obviously untrue right what
twitter is saying is
yeah look we think there this happens
every so often
um first of all we've never seen this
happen before and it's not happening
evenly it's only happening to
conservatives
but they're saying look what happens is
there are a lot of accounts we don't
know if they're real accounts or not
so we just take all of them out of the
follower accounts and then
as people confirm their details then all
of a sudden we add them back
in but if that were true then
all the conservatives i guess everybody
including liberals their follower
accounts would drop dramatically
and then slowly increase as people
confirm those details
that's not what's happening the follower
counts are steadily decreasing but only
for conservatives and the only time it's
not steady is when you're talking about
the president of the united states
and associated accounts which have been
shut down
by some hipster-looking
radical oligarch in silicon valley named
jack dorsey who runs twitter
now you might say okay well you have no
right to use twitter's platform
twitter's a private company after all
sort of
we'll get into that in a second
what what very often liberals and
squishy
conservatives fake conservatives have
said for in recent years is
make your own twitter oh come on you
have no right to use jack dorsey's
platform make your own twitter
yeah okay maybe dorsey and zuckerberg
and google have conquered the entire
public square and they now control
discourse in our republic
but look private company they can do
whatever they want
the problem with this are there are many
problems with this argument but the main
one the most
obvious problem with this argument is
you can't make your own twitter
when they say go make your own twitter
they won't let you make your own twitter
dan bongino did go make his own twitter
he called it parlor
and he put it up there and then when
twitter started censoring conservatives
a lot of conservatives went over there
and then google and apple came out and
they said
we're not going to allow parlor on our
operating systems they're not going to
be in the app store
so i guess if you've got it installed
good for you for now but that's it
it's it's over google and apple
control 99 of the
mobile operating system market share
99 if they kick you out of their stores
you're gone from cell phones
so they won't let you make your own
twitter okay well hold on you can still
access parlor through the web browser on
your phone can't you
sure you can't use the app but you have
no right google and apple private
companies sort of
so you have no right to force your app
into their app store just go on the web
browser
well that's what parlor said they would
do and guess what amazon web services
the web host said that parlor's not
allowed to even have a website
if you go to parlor.com right now
chances are it will not load
now dan friend of the show
says that he's got a backup plan i hope
parlor is back online quickly
but how long before that web server
says no we're not going to host you
either this happened
to uh gab gab was this this
alternative to twitter that came up
before parlor did
same thing kicked out of the app stores
kicked off their web hosting their
domain registrar godaddy
they couldn't even get the website so
all of a sudden we go from
build your own twitter come on just
build your own twitter to
come on build your own mobile operating
system
to build your own cell phone
to build your own web servers to build
your own
domain registrar to build your own
internet to i guess build your own
government is that the end of it oh wait
a second that's what we should have been
doing the whole time
we should have been engaging in politics
so that we could
wield political systems when the people
gave us power
and the fact that we did not do that on
the right
is the fault of conservatives
you know we stopped engaging in politics
and
part of the reason for this is that we
took expressions like andrew breitbart's
favorite
famous expression when he said politics
is downstream of culture that's
obviously true
to a degree but we took an expression
like that
as an excuse not to engage in politics
we we took it as an excuse to say well
no
government it's always bad whenever
government does anything
and that's why you need to elect us so
that we won't do anything that you want
us to do
and we need to let big business run
roughshod over our culture
because we've we've exclusively got to
focus on the culture
and not on politics well look where
that's gotten us
as if by the way there was some totally
distinct line between culture and
politics
there obviously isn't culture affects
politics movies and tv
and books and art affects politics
and politics affects culture we know
that conservatives are willing to admit
that in our most candid moments
right when conservatives talk about the
disastrous policies of lbj and the great
society
all those welfare programs that trapped
people in generations of poverty
that was politics affecting culture
wasn't it thomas soul writes about this
all the time
when he says black americans were doing
a whole lot better before the great
society
and then the great society comes in and
all of a sudden they start doing much
worse
what changed did the movies change i
guess a little bit did the art change
yeah sure
no what changed is the government policy
obviously
politics can shape culture
and and i think it's uh just a recourse
for people
who in a cowardly way don't want to
engage in the political system
who don't want to go in and say no big
tech you don't get to do that we're
going to break you up we're going to
break you up under antitrust laws
we're going to break you up because of
section 230 of the communications
decency act
we're going to bake break you up because
of the fraud that you've engaged in
this was so predictable this was so
predictable
they they had been signaling this for
months the minute that twitter
put a fact check on the president's
tweet
i thought it's only a matter of time
before they kick them off
the fact check was so ridiculous you
remember trump said we
i think we won the election and then
twitter says this claim is disputed
but they didn't really mean this claim
is disputed any claim on social media
could be disputed
and if a claim is disputed that means
that the counter claim is disputed too
but they didn't when
biden said we won the election they
didn't put a claim that said this claim
is disputed too obviously that claim was
disputed by trump
they had picked aside well okay
fair enough
questions of free speech and censorship
i suppose people can pick a side
but are we comfortable whatever you
think about whatever you think about the
election whatever you think about joe
biden whatever you think about donald
trump
ask yourself this are you really
comfortable
with a handful of radical left-wing
oligarchs in silicon valley billionaires
censoring the duly elected president i
did not elect
elect jack dorsey i did not elect mark
zuckerberg
and conservatives helped this happen
the left is i don't want a victim blame
the left is the aggressor here
conservatives let it happen how did we
let it happen well first of all
we had four years of the trump
administration and two years of unified
government
to to attack big tech bring them down to
size
we didn't do it do you know what we did
instead we called in the big tech
executives
and then the legislators got really good
sound bites
on tv yelling at the big tech executives
and they got
really good campaign commercials out of
it and then nothing happened
and then mark zuckerberg goes on tv and
he says yes
we have to do better oh we willed yes oh
i'd
oh this was bad and we'll do better and
he's obviously lying
right he's obviously not telling the
truth because they didn't do better they
they got a lot worse
at least jack dorsey to his credit he's
never even
pretended to care jack dorsey it
looks like hipster rasputin with his
beard and he basically says
i don't i don't care about any of you
guys
so we let that happen but the problem's
even deeper than that
and it's going to take a lot of soul
searching on the right
republicans have been shilling for big
business
for decades now for decades
really starting i guess in the 70s but
really ramping up in the
80s 90s and 2000s
conservatives have been shilling for
giant multinational corporations that
hate our culture
that ship our jobs overseas that don't
give a damn about this country
they've embraced this line build your
own twitter oh you can never
tell mark zuckerberg what to do he has
his sacred right to censor the president
it's his platform we shield i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the michael
knowles show
to check out the full episode hit the
link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you